lequel de ces deux fromages est une
mozzarella les deux la mozzarella
fraîche seaux fromages blancs à pâte
molle
on vend qui fait soit à base de lait de
vache ou de lait de bufflonne puis ont
le vent dans le dos ou dans l'art sonore
c'est quelque chose qui est censé être
consommés frais dans son état à ces
frais là quelques semaines leur maximum
après sa production versus la mozzarella
qu'on achète en épicier sous forme de
briques ou râper dans des grands sacs
avec une texture beaucoup plus
différente
la teneur en humidité c'est vraiment le
gros point de différenciation donc la
matériel à frêche est un fromage qui est
plus humide donc la texture est beaucoup
plus molle beaucoup plus onctueuse le
goût et est plus délicat tandis que le
moteur est là qu'on va appeler disons
est régulière et plus sec donc le goût
est un monsieur qui prononce un peu plus
à l'est ce qui fait en sorte que le
brunissement va se faire un petit peu
mieux soit un petit peu plus fondants
parce que la teneur en humidité est
moins élevé bien on peut la garder sur
les tablettes un peu plus longtemps car
moi j'étais jeune je travaille ici
c'était la mariée aux orignaux et
propriétaire de la friterie milano a
promis stella mois salhab c'est comme si
moi j'ai faite par morceau de jambe à
des traits qu'on rendait l'âme à celle
là où tout début après son avion c'est
sûr qu'en italie ça fait des années des
années qu'ils ont plusieurs choix quand
on tente de mozzarella patricia au
couteau de la bd fromage se spécialise
dans l'importation des fromages d'italie
la mozzarella di buffala ça fait depuis
le 16e siècle qui en produisent en
italie alors c'est vraiment une
tradition qui date depuis très très
longtemps
les derniers 10 15 ans on en voit de
plus en plus grâce à l'importation de
produits ainsi produit le lait
mozzarella fraîche qui viennent de
l'italie arrivent par avion pour que ça
arrive vraiment frais pour les italiens
la mozzarella c'est un peu comme le
fromage en grains pour nous les
québécois à pour les italiens la
mozzarella de bufflonne c'est vraiment
ce produit qu'on mange quotidiennement
c'est quelque chose qu'on va chercher à
tous les jours on en mange presque tous
les jours alors peut-être à ce niveau là
oui ça se compare
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi nous avait la pêche et
les saveurs de l'italie session s'est
dit pour que le goût de la et délaissent
salé saint paul koudou oui c'est plus
douce et sucrée ans paola degiovanni est
achetée chez milano depuis dix ans il
est à lille la mozzarella du labour à
tes mots série a di buffala c'est de
l'eau de l'eau blanche ces deux là je
connais ça y est c'est le rouble a
commencé à aller vers les jo c'est
l'argent cet or blanc porte plusieurs
noms mozzarella fiore délatté di buffala
burrata bocconcini des noms qui évoquent
l'italie bien sûr mais quelles en sont
les différences amateurs et leurs frères
h
on la retrouve sous deux formes soit
faite à base de lait de bufflonne savait
toujours indiquer si on la retrouve sous
le nom de fioles du lartet dans le fond
en thalys salsa traduction pour fleur de
l'est ça c'est un produit à base de lait
de vache
ensuite on parle de beaucoup une chimie
puis beaucoup en chine et de la
traduction c'est bouché donc on parle de
boucher de m'attraper leur ferait donc
là on a vraiment le même processus plus
ou moins que la mozzarella puis
différentes déclinaisons l'antenne de
brossard on en trouve plusieurs
différentes tailles
il avouera tassé une enveloppe de
mozzarella fraîche et puis à l'intérieur
il ya un mélange de crème et des petits
morceaux de mozzarella fraîche alors
cette crème et 7 mozzarella fraîche et
enrobés est enveloppé par un sac de
mozzarella fraîche qu'on enveloppe voilà
on a deux laboratoires les restaurants
italiens nous ont d'abord fait connaître
le mariage des tomates et beaucoup de
chimie à montreuil
5 août meilleur quand s'est déchiré avec
les doigts vanessa nous propose de bien
belle et bonne façon de mettre en valeur
toutes les formes de mozzarella en
cuisine pour l'amateur elle a un beau
changement automatique pendant l'été
c'est de combiner ça avec des pêches
grillé donc on fait qu'après sa base de
page
ça permet justement de beaux masques et
le fromage mais vraiment juste de le
rehausser une idée avec ses fromages
frais là on va quand même garder c'est
assez simple pour pas à rajouter trop de
chaleur parce que ça ça va venir changer
la texture place avant une belle
combinaison ça serait avec des figues
fraîches un petit peu projetons de
fromage keynote donc un petit peu de
salé avec le prosciutto puis le sucré
avec les filles c'est super beau puis un
petit peu de salade de roquette pour un
petit peu de piquant donc ces petites
combinaisons simples on personnes cette
ville d'auch lipides balsamique puis
c'est fait la burrata faisait quelque
chose qu'on voit de plus en plus même
dans les restaurants maintenant de
racheter une touche de burrata vraiment
sur le plot fini de pâte puis vraiment
la chaleur départ de venir faire sortir
la crème dans la burrata c'est délicieux
mais en termes de recettes
on peut ajouter ça des salades des
salades de pâtes commissariat de pesto à
laquelle on rajoute des brunes chimie à
la fin ou une salade plus steeple
antipasto donc avec des cars d'artichaut
des tomates séchées un petit peu de
radicchio on peut rajouter 100
l'intérieur donc ça reste des choses
assez simples qu'on peut retrouver
normalement dans le garde-manger la cli
bocconcini sas rajoute est très
simplement à la fin pour acheter un
petit crème ans
voilà des idées qui met l'eau à la
bouche qu'en est il maintenant des
valeurs nutritives
quand le produit est à haute teneur en
humidité naturellement ils ont produit
un petit peu moins gras la burrata la
crème fait en sorte que oui la teneur en
matière grasse a donc un petit peu ça
tourne plus autour du 24 % mais
surprenamment la mozzarella sèche
régulière ton mouton ou six dans 24%
donc ça reste des fromages qui sont pas
extrêmement riche en matériaux mais je
dirais que la burrata sont alès ça
demeure une question portion le donc sa
demeure à 24 pour ça pour la portion
diminue pour déguster la fraîcheur venu
d'ailleurs et vous être prêts à payer le
prix
évidemment ça peut donner étant donné
qu'on doit le faire rentrer au canada
par avion parce que la durée de vie est
très courte
s'ajoutent au coût il ya le coût du
transport qui vient s'ajouter au coût du
produit on peut payer jusqu'à 96 dollars
le kilo pour une bulle rata italienne
des entreprises canadiennes produisent
aussi des mozzarella fraîche sous
diverses formes même de la burrata et de
la mozzarella de bufflonne et les offres
à des prix souvent moins élevé et ça se
compare avec ce qu'on peut manger en
italie
ceux de bufflonne son nom c'est quand
même des bons produits mais autre que
l'ingrédient de base qui est du lait de
bufflonne le produit ne votent pas
nécessairement la même chose c'est ce
qu'on a c'est difficile d'avoir un
produit vraiment très très frais
d'italie donc on peut avoir un produit
délicieux tout aussi frais québécois le
calpi on peut satisfaire de ceux-là
définitivement